assalamualaikum greetings of peace I'm
on my way to pick up the next guess for
this week's show and you're probably
wondering what a nice we're thinking
what a nice scenery isn't it like where
you going Eddie well I'm going to get
this special guest for this week's show
and you're you might be I know if you
can tell I'm actually limping also not
too long ago i'll have into in the video
description i talked about the beautiful
blessing of the the body being able to
heal itself i broke my toe at that time
and guess what that was about six months
ago broke my my toe and then come to
find out i also tore my never heard of
this plantar plate but alhamdulillah it
healed and just a couple weeks ago I
broke the neighboring toe what else can
you do but say alhamdulillah and have
for hope shall i'll get better we got
exciting show for you this week with my
next guess you'll learn about him when i
go get him when he comes on stay tuned
and don't forget if you haven't
subscribed right now
you